Sabin says she is struggling to recover
after being shot by an Israeli
soldier she was one of only three female
paramedics working with ambulance crews
in the city of Janine in the occupied
West
[Music]
Bank this is the moment the bullet
smashed through the ambulance's back
door and ripped into her back narrowly
missing her
spine
I was trying to help the injured and I
thought I was safe because I was inside
the ambulance when the first bullet hit
me the pain was incredible as I lost
Consciousness all I could think about
was my
daughter's Palestinian Medics are in
danger more than ever before since the
beginning of the
war do you want to film inside this
medic asks Israeli soldiers who have
blocked his
path the Israeli Army is stopping
Palestinian Medics reaching or
transporting the
wounded often threatening them at
gunpoint threatening their lives as they
try to save the lives of
others Mahmud assadi still suffers pain
from the burn injuries he suffered 20
years ago when this ambulance he was
working in was attacked by the Israeli
Army the violations are worse now
because they are more violent since the
war started the soldiers forced Medics
out of the ambulances and strip search
them ordering them on their knees at
gunpoint they trained their guns laser
sights on our chests as a direct threat
and they pushed the ambulances out of
the area by using their military
vehicles this ambulance is riddled with
bullet holes you don't get much clearer
evidence than this that the Israeli Army
is targeting Medical Teams as it tries
to get to and treat the wounded there's
another hole here there's a couple here
there's an exit hole here where a bullet
has come right the way through the
vehicle and there's another one here on
the back door Medical Teams tell us that
despite putting in repeated official
complaints to the Israeli army they have
had zero
response this is an Israeli armored
bulldozer at the gates of one of
Janine's
hospitals doctors say the Israeli Army
surrounds all three of the city
government hospitals during its almost
nightly raids hunting members of the
Palestinian armed
[Music]
resistance they surround us and sto the
ambulances from reaching us or leaving
they stopped the doctors from doing
their jobs the hospital has been hit by
tear gas during which staff and patients
inside suffered gas
inhalation Sabrine says she wants to go
back to work but shrapnel is still stuck
close to her spine and she needs another
operation what but she says she is
scared because her injury means she
won't be able to save lives as well as
she did before Charles statford Al jazer
Janine the occupied West Bank